こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
ゴールデンウィーク
よだれでた
ゴールデンウィークなんですけども
日曜日
遊戯王カード
遊戯王カードの
公民大会に行ったんですけども
結果は
準優勝でした
決勝でまけたんだよな〜
もうね
まじね
もう一歩で
勝てそうなところで
ちょっと
やられちまったよ
俺は今非常に悔しい
でもな
俺はわかったんだよ
こんな俺でも
決勝まで進める
俺の熱い魂
感じただろ？
な？
というわけで今日はな？
あの〜
ちょっと遊戯王の
し過ぎで
時間が無くて
今日はパパっと
やろう
パパっと
テキトーにやります　今日は
今日はこちらです
みんなの玉子！！
賞味期限もうね
ちょっと
切れちゃってるんですけども
卵があるんだけれども
ちょっと噂で聞いたんですけども
この卵
手で握っても
割れないらしいです
今日はね
この俺様が
実際にこの卵をね手でね
というわけで今日はね
このハンディングでね
卵を
ぶち割ってやろうと
思います
なんか生きてない？
結構、賞味期限切れちゃってるから
生きてるかもしんない
え？大丈夫だよね？
ひよことか生まれないよね
あの
マジで
なんか
分かんないんだよ俺も
信憑性とかはどうかわかんないんだけども
ネットで聞く限り
なんか
腕だけで割れないって聞いたんで
この卵をね
腕だけで割ってみようと思います
やばい割れちゃった
ひびが入ってたら余裕でわれるんすよ
ひびが入ってて、手で割れるのは
全然わかるんだけれども
この
普通の状態で割れるかどうかって言われると
俺はわかんない
割と固いな
え？待って
割と固い
え？まじで割れないんだけど
割れない割れないガチで割れない
え？待って？
割れないんだけど
はじめて知った
痛っ
え？マジで割れない
あ〜っ
やべっ